l a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su
wars this che in realtà dovrebbe essere
tipo misto tra un videogioco rage quindi
tipo super meat boy è un videogioco
horror
c'è un mix delle due cose ha vinto 1
labirinto 2 labirinto 1 salve io
qualcuno mi spiega come si gioca st
cagata per favore
devo prendere le monete va bene io devo
correre ma c'è gente in suo posto state
pregando una torcia gigante il dio
torcia io non sono nessuno per dire che
voi non dovete pregare le torce quindi
me ne vado a [ __ ]
in teoria dovrebbe essere un horror
salve
lei non prega le torce non ho provate è
il tasso è quello devo saltare ma posso
saltare
non era difficile ma piano sono forte io
ciao zio c'era un tipo che è andato dico
a prima
cazzo ma una tartaruga ninja cerca di
merda cosa
cioè voglio dire [ __ ]
cos'è sta roba se n'è andato a fun cool
bene era quello che volevo sparito unica
[ __ ] che gioco brutto non volevano
nemmeno possiamo cambiare sa quanto sei
bello sembri un mini godzilla sentiti
posso comprare delle cose tipo un divano
tipo dei fiori tieni tutti x te niente
non vi posso dare la affanculo vabbè
pazienza e io io scendo c'erano delle
spine sul soffitto vero io sono un
[ __ ] però quando si sapeva già tutta
una barca laida lercia perché vede vista
carte
cos'è che casino bene ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi non sto capello io non mi faccio
i cazzi degli altri di solito pro per
chi stai venerando un televisore
cacciavo non mi faccio i cazzi e gli
altri ma bene alla vita di merda e vabbè
sono vivo non ci credono veramente
dov'è ah ok lui è diventato un modello
adesso
[Musica]
se lo seguo dovrei avere uno sconto del
20 per cento sui i capi ebert crohn di
vero
sì perché ecco infatti non ve n'era più
televisore posso venerarlo io il
pomeriggio 5 barbara d'urso non ho
capito dove stiamo andando ma ok mamma
barbara d'urso sa che corre di qua
adesso sono quasi convinto che questa
cosa infatti io corro veloce
c'è un tizio qua ragazzi come faccio a
superarlo
ma no perché sono morto mi sono rotto i
[ __ ] non avendo addirittura
incazzate ste ventole molto incazzata e
ste ventole ancora ragazzi mi spiega
dove sto andando che non lo so neanch'io
sei passato da starbucks grazie
[Musica]
cosa ha detto di mia madre o siamo
ritornati dove c'era la lucertola
gigante di prima perfetto era volevo
proprio tornare in questo posto allora
la lucertola di prima ma la fate vedere
sospetto non la voglio vedere se punterà
la [ __ ] vacca infarti che prendo quando
gli era una vita che non va neanche
doubt las li prendevo gli infarti così
sulla si alza come minimo è invece è
veramente un misto tra se stesso ma non
parlasse di tre secondi è veramente un
misto tra un range game è un horror
l'unico problema che non capisco cosa
devo fare ho trovato un hamburger
prefetto a codice 88 perché sento dei
passi da pino il cazzo vuoi farci
dell'eterna un pene ma è un bene quello
ma che brutta cosa
non volevo vederlo ce n'è anche piccola
non trovare un codice perfetto sarà
dietro la lucertola perché ci sono
uomini morti in mutande almeno lui e
mutande cela bene lucertola parte devo
trovare un cazzo di codice in
continuatore del va bene niente trovare
un
il [ __ ] codice che hanno tenuto bene
da dove posso comprare una playstation a
cosa cazzo mi serve iscriviti
cosa cazzo nola dove parola comprato una
per quanto non senso sto gioco di qua ma
non c'era la lucertola qui prima va bene
apri è vero ma c'è un ascensore che
bello non sono perfetto giusta visto
pagatissimo porca [ __ ] sono cagato mi
sono buttato e stata una morte
bellissima non ho capito cosa ho appena
giocato ma va bene labirinto 2 tanto il
primo più o meno avevamo visto tutto
tranne la parte che era chiusa col
codice proprio questo più o meno c'era e
allora la persecuzione fino al trump mi
spiego si fa donald trump tra i
personaggi cento dei passi che che sta
camminando lega ciao ma in realtà questo
quella specie di tendini reality show
altro che grande fratello vip questo è
il labirinto dove ti ammazzano con le
lucertole grosse vip aprire aprirsi la
sorella c'è un codice di là che palle
costi codici non trovo neanche non li
trovo c'è una chiave salvezza
devo tornare dove lo prima che c'era la
porta chiusa con la verde ora chiede se
con la chiave sul mondo
melo su chi come me che ho fatto a
ritrovarla
apriti cielo chiave testa di minchia no
dai non ci credo manco quella che allora
cosa vuoi
a questo serve stamera infilo nel
deretano la chiave spiega ma la porta
azzurra era questa la porta li mortacci
tua di tua sorella la budria che c'hai
al posto della panza e c'è anche la
chiave per la porta rossa che non ho
idea di dove sia ma va bene su tutte le
chiavi delle porte perfetto questo che
la porta rossa è quindi la chiave verde
dove ecco la porta rossa porca eva ho
trovato tutto sono un fenomeno 9
amichevole con la verde a riportarci sua
come la prendo però perfetto ragazzo
anche la chiave verde ciò abbiamo tutto
se non fosse che non mi ricordo più dove
sono le porte ma quello potrebbe essere
un problema
mio mandato ma
andate affanculo avere ragazzi sono
morto così avevo la chiave il codice
pavimento avevo finito male ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto è stato
alquanto strano ma va bene lasciamo
perdere un bel live soprattutto per
donald trump che non c'entrava una sega
proceda messo dentro a caso la vicenda
se entro 100 quinto è un mi piace anche
a pagine di facebook quindi dotata
descrizione tu sei figli siete riusciti
schiavone prossimo vitobello ragazzi